A las afueras de la ciudad de kungo en
mayot yacen un montón de láminas de
metal y bloques de hormigón las
excavadoras comenzaron a derribar uno de
los mayores barrios de invasión de La
Isla el lunes por la mañana
el objetivo lo he dicho es acabar con la
invasión de terrenos y avanzar hacia el
acceso a la vivienda Esa es la política
de mayor así que Seguiremos demoliendo
la operación se ha un mes
debido a las impugnaciones judiciales
denominada One bushu que significa
recuperar en lengua local su objetivo no
es solo luchar contra la infravivienda
sino también contra la migración
irregular muchos ciudadanos atribuyen el
creciente problema delincuencia de La
Isla a los migrantes irregulares que se
enfrentan a la Pobreza por la falta de
oportunidades laborales los residentes
de unos 160 barrios de Invasión se ven
obligados a hacer las maletas y
marcharse para siempre un golpe
desgarrador para esta madre trabajadora
trabajo
duro en este mundo para criar a mis
siete hijos trabajo y pago impuestos
como todo el mundo
las autoridades locales dicen que han
ofrecido viviendas sociales a los
desplazados pero que pocos las han
aceptado muchos dicen que no quieren ser
reubicados muchos más temen ser
expulsados la mitad de los 350.000
habitantes de mallot no tienen
nacionalidad francesa y la mayoría de
los migrantes indocumentados proceden de
las vecinas Islas comoras que se
independizaron de Francia en 1974 la
operación ha provocado un conflicto
diplomático con comoras que se ha negado
a admitir a sus ciudadanos expulsados
las autoridades francesas dicen que
planean demoler unas mil viviendas
irregulares en maillot en los próximos
meses